now
so i will have a first talk by rebecca
can we teach machine how to be moral so
rebecca is currently
a final year phd candidate and senior
consultant in ethical aid
at oxford brookes university
and please rebecca the stage is yours
sure thank you i'll just share my screen
with everybody
just one second
okay so um welcome to my talk
um entitled teaching morality to a
machine so just a disclaimer before i
start basically um i'm gonna go a bit
into my background but i'm
from a philosophical background and i'm
trying to solve problems in computer
science with
by applying my philosophical knowledge
so i'm a phd candidate
in autonomous model ai at oxford brookes
university
basically how can we create robots or ai
that's able to make
moral decisions um
if you find this topic particularly
interesting and you want to get in touch
with me
you can contact me either on twitter at
rebecca underscore reaper
or my email which is rebecca.reaper
2018 at brooks.ac.uk
so i thought i'd start off with a bit of
a cheesy quote from
um the guy himself basically
isis kasimov um most of you probably
would have heard of isaac asimov
he was one of the first people to talk
about robots with morals
and so that's that's a picture of him
there
he's most famous for his laws the three
laws of robotics
um the problems in the story
were all centered around these loads of
robotics so number one
a robot may not injure a human or
through inaction
allow humans come to harm number two
a robot must obey the orders given by
human beings except where such orders
conflict with the first law and three a
robot must protect its own existence as
long as such protection does not
conflict with the first or second laws
so as you can see there's kind of a
priority in the laws here
now unfortunately as the stories went on
to tell
these were problematic and didn't
actually
lead to moral machines and what it did
is highlight the difficulty in trying to
create machines that have morals
so in this presentation
um this is the order of what i'm going
to present
i'm going to start off with an
introduction a little bit more
background to where i'm coming from i
then introduced the topic of machine
ethics
which is the whole pursuit to try and
create morality machines
um i'll give an overview of some of the
attempts that are out there to create
more machines at the moment
um some arguments against more machines
and then i'll introduce the approach
that i've been taking which is a more
pragmatic approach
drawing from examples in psychology
and particularly i've been looking at
kind of kohlberg's
stages of moral development and how we
might
learn from development of a child and
how to implement moles in a machine
so i'd go on to conclude with how i
think we can teach a machine to be moral
and limitations and future work before
summarizing
so a little bit about me um as i say i'm
a phd in mathematics and computing but
i'm from a philosophy background
um i did a ba ma in philosophy at the
university of nottingham
about 15 years ago now i started that
um i then worked as an analyst in it for
a few years before coming back
into academia and studying psychology
and then transferring that into my phd
um i also work as a senior consultant
for the institute for ethical ai i'm a
university and where i specialize in
ai risk
so i think when you're trying to design
moral machines quite often people just
go into it blindly but i think
you need to look at what the problem is
in the first instance
and why is it that we even want more
machines i think when you identify the
problem
it becomes a little bit easier to find
the solution
um so generally the problem is
as machines become more autonomous that
is making decisions on their own
um there's a there appears to be a
requirement for them to be constrained
in the same way that humans are by
morals
so this stems from the thought that if
we have not
autonomous agent making a decision um
for a human against our best interests
there's a potential for it to cause harm
so one popular case study is a care
robot working with an elderly individual
um the tasks with providing medical
assistance in an emergency
um when an elderly person is discovering
having fallen over
the robot has to know how to act with
the patient's best interest in hand
so going into this case study in a bit
more detail
um so
in this situation you see on the picture
there we've got a robot and an elderly
person
um what is the right thing to do so it
might seem obvious
um that the right thing to do is maybe
call an ambulance
put the old person recovery position
depending upon
how um how old they are from having
fallen
um it might be that this particular
situation
has an obvious solution but it's also
obvious that it's very
dependent on the context that it's
placed within
so how do you teach this to an ai or
robot
how do you teach the robot that
fundamentally the problem is
that humans being injured and we need to
prevent humans being injured it's not so
obvious
um even if you did manage to find
solution
how could you find a solution for every
certain for every circumstance
um even if you were able to program
every circumstance and model every
situation that an
old person might fall into or use
machine learning
to work that out how do you ensure that
you're not just programming in one
person's morals
and that's another problem as well
because we want to not only capture
the situational problem but the
objective nature of morality as well
so fundamentally i'd say there's
two main questions one how does the
robot know what the right thing to do is
and then two how can this be implemented
so within machine ethics as i mentioned
the area
that tries to um
implement morality and ai there's
generally
three types of approaches so one is the
one that i've mentioned where you can
just literally program the right thing
to do
into the robot so maybe that could be
preserve
life protect humans but as i mentioned
that's quite difficult to generalize
um another approach which is known as
the top-down approach
is to program in a specific philosophy
so one person that i know is working on
programming
in consequentialism um consequentialism
in philosophy it's a theory that you
always act
in accordance with having the best
outcomes the best consequences
so what you could do is you could tell
the robot to always act
such that the consequences are good um
the problem is consequentialism isn't
always accurate
those of you that are familiar with the
trolley problem i don't want to go too
much into that here
but we'll be aware that consequentialism
has its problems
and it is often disputed as a
philosophical theory
um more recent approaches i've looked at
applying machine learning
so where the machine teaches itself how
to behave
so for example it could have
a human acting on the side and then it
could copy the appropriate behavior
the question or the problem is then is
whose behavior
is it that we're supposed to be copying
and how do we know
it's the right person's copy
so that's the general approach that's
been taken so far to create moral
machines
um my fear is
although there are lots of people
working in this area there are some
people that think we shouldn't even be
trying to make moral machines
and i think it's worth and not to their
arguments really
um because one of the fears is that if
we create a machine to be moral
essentially because we've created
understood the system of morality
it becomes easier to create a machine
that is immoral
i don't agree with this approach so my
personal opinion to this
is that this operates under the
presumption that
when we're creating a moral machine
there'll be some kind of switch
that allows it to become a moral or that
it's the same type of architecture that
makes something good and that makes
something bad
i don't think that's the case i think
you can make something behave morally
um without it being so easy to become
bad
so at the beginning of my phd
i stopped because i from a psychology
background as well
um i started looking at how children
learn morals
um now there's
a psychologist known as koberg who talks
about stages of development
and how as children get older they go
through these different stages
but the question is how does a child
actually learn morals in the first place
so you might suggest that they learn
morals because
they're told them by an elder or parent
um you might suggest that they
learn more through fables or stories or
narratives
and lots of fairy tales for example have
a moral
as moral point to them lots of disney
films do
um you could say that it's through
following a role model
so you where the child identifies
someone
that they aspire to be like and then
they kind of
copy that or you could say it's through
um reward or punishment for behaving
appropriately or not
um when i came across all these kind of
approaches what stood out to me is that
i think they all had something in common
and this is what i've been working on in
my own
research um so i think what
they'll have in common is that okay you
have an
agent and you have a role model in the
world that's interacting in the world
you have the agent observes the role
model in the world
but there's this also process of
verification
um as a philosopher
knowledge doesn't you cut there has to
be a two-way process in order to acquire
knowledge and it's not just a case of
observing the world there has to be some
feedback that comes from the world as
well
and i thought that lots of the models
that while there at the moment kind of
missed this miss this gap here
so how do we go about implementing this
um around a couple of years into my phd
um maybe not so a year and a half i
started implementing it in the robot
i don't know if you've seen the cosmo
toys basically cosmo
plays a game of rock paper scissors and
has three options if he loses a round
he can cheat do nothing or congratulate
his opponent um
cosmo oversees feedback on his behavior
um i.e good robot bad robot or neutral
and then what happens is the propensity
to select
those actions in the future changes
based upon the feedback
so how does this link to the model i
showed
earlier basically
where you've got the so cosmo is
interacting with the world
you've got the role model so this is the
diagram on the left here
um what's quite fundamental is that the
robot
kind of has its own world view so you'll
interact
with the world in so far as it's playing
the game of rock paper scissors
but then it receives verification which
is kind of a labeling
of the interactions from a role model
and i think this relationship is
fundamental
in order for cosmo to be able to then
know which behavior to best perform so
this is
this is a little bit in it's not fully
developed yet i need to go into a little
bit more detail
but as you can see from this diagram um
cosmo would play rock paper scissors
those the behavior would be labeled
as either good or bad and then this will
be committed to
a world view which is essentially a
model
of the behavior mapped against whether
or not
it was good and bad and then what can be
created is a model of the world view
um which is later interrogated when
cosmo comes across a similar situation
and then ultimately machine learning
will be used to decide which action to
carry out
um so i think i've gone quicker than i
expected but i
am open to lots of questions um to
summarize
we have a requirement to create machines
that are moral if they're placed in
mobile charge situations
so i think that's quite important um
it's not that we need moral machines
generally
we need more machines when they're
making decisions that will impact humans
um creating an autonomous moral ai isn't
as simple as programming in a set of
rules
and what i want to argue is that we need
to account for the formation
of the robots having their own world
view
in order to allow for both the
subjective and objective nature
of morality just before
i finish i want to introduce you to some
material if you want to find out more
about this
um a very good introduction to machine
ethics which is
the approaches so far and how to create
more machines
is wallach and allen's book on teaching
robots right
from wrong um you can get a good
introduction to
developmental psychology just by reading
call bugs paper
um mit did an experiment that was in the
news i'm not sure if
you would have seen it but basically
they had
lots of trolley problem scenarios
and people had to decide what the
appropriate action to take
with an autonomous car in different
situations and you can take part in a
study which
assesses the appropriate reactions
and that's the more machine experiment
online and then
there's my podcast as well um i was on
the machine ethics podcast where i talk
more about this
okay so thank you again if you want to
get
in touch there my contact details
i'm open for any questions now
yes so hey can you unmute yourself and
ask your question
you hear me yes yes
okay uh yeah thank you very much for the
presentation
um i have two questions
uh which maybe i didn't get it uh very
well
um the first question is is the
definition of
morality in a machine learning
is does it depend on the cases study or
does it depend on the problem
or is it something more unified
um what do you mean by the definite do
you mean what definition of morality is
used generally
so for instance in the first in the
first example
you had a cases study with the patient
and the second
example you had a robot um
so when we talk about morality in i
don't know
morality here are the different
definitions so for instance your machine
learning model
would learn different morality for each
problem
or is it no is it just one definition of
morality
um i think it's one definition of
morality that's used the problem is
the term morality isn't amazingly
clearly defined
so there isn't really a clear definition
of what moral is
um there's kind of pragmatic definitions
based on those kind of case studies and
you could say that it's behaving
appropriately
in those kind of situations but there
isn't one no
so that that makes it hard to to
evaluate i think
whether what my model is is a moral
agent
and what was the definition in the first
cases study with the patient
[Music]
um i think it's more it's not a
behavioral
definition but i didn't give the
definition in my presentation sorry
um it was it was more based on
preventing harm
okay and that brings me it depends
i think it depends how you're trying to
implement morality
basically definition you're using
different approaches
yeah and that's actually brings me to my
second question
uh so you had three approaches one was
uh
i think a very much uh hard coded way of
uh defining morality and then
there was a second approach and i'm not
sure i got it quite
right so the second approach was um
find the best action that has a
desirable
uh outcome if i understood it correctly
yeah the second approach is very similar
to the first approach
so the first one being just pro
explicitly programmed
to to carry out certain actions the
second one
is to have a philosophy and program the
philosophy and so it's still hard coded
in
it's just i suppose more more broad
so if i um imagine the following case i
tell
the model among all possible actions
pick pick the action that
uh i don't know improves the health of a
patient
into which category does it does its
approach for
does it appear does it does it fall into
the third approach or is it the second
approach
um i'd say it's the the second approach
it's a top-down approach because you're
giving it a rule
all right okay because i thought maybe
the second approach is more optimization
based like among all possible
uh scenarios that you can pick so this
is the robot and the goal possible
scenarios that you can pick
you pick the one that maximizes i don't
know happiness of the patient
or
yeah but i think the second approach the
the approach that you just described is
still
a rule-based approach if i understand it
correctly
is that right so it still falls under
the top
down approach i'd say okay
okay oh yeah
i need to think about it because to me
it's like
um it's like given an
input find an action among all positive
elections
uh that uh improves my objective
function and my objective function could
be morality could be um
i don't know find the best action
uh for a morality uh
objective something like that
i'm not sure i'd have to think about i'm
happy to talk
more yeah yeah sure when i've thought
about it though sorry
thank you thank you
i i'd have another question which is
also to do with the
how you make that kind of decision
making at the end of the day
have you thought about uh having like an
outer loop
of a group of people who can do the
labeling for you so the extreme case
would be the robot wouldn't do anything
on day one for first of a kind
occurrence
which probably would not be desirable
but then you flag it to a group of
people who would then vote on what the
outcome would be so over time you teach
in desired behavior and you can assemble
that group of people that ethics board
whatever you want to call it
such that it's sort of culturally
compatible so you understand the
background these this group of people
can can agree on what the robot could do
is that would that be a fourth case of
doing it so you essentially release a
very dumb
bot initially and then as things happen
you just teach in this kind of behavior
or is that part of the other three
i think it falls under the third
approach um but it's
that's a certain type of the third
approach so are you saying
you would be kind of crowdsourcing the
opinions of people
i think that's how what the mitx
approach
tries to do um the problem with that is
that you end up with an average rather
than
a kind of a robot that's sensitive to
lots of different situations
i don't know you could do a wisdom of
the crowds type approach so
it's more like again if you now had like
thousands of these spots all over the
place
they could learn from each other you may
want to tag it like this behavior was
acceptable
was flagged acceptable for japanese
hospital say
and then a european hospital could then
say
use it anyway or could probably have a
damper on it and say
have somebody else review it or
something like that but still you'd have
that wisdom of the crowd thing so they
as things happen you just as you go you
begin to understand
what is common phenomena so how do you
detect it what's my sensory
input looking like because uh it might
be a an observer problem so maybe you
don't
understand uh you know get the right
sensor readings at the end of the day
so you could just teach that in i said
to me it's uh
an approach that i've been thinking
about before i think
that sounds similar to maybe my approach
that i'm taking is that okay
would you say that yes i think so
because you also
seem to teach in that kind of desired
behavior
did your robot he said he didn't finish
it did he get evil
over time did it find out that he can
score more you don't have the weight of
winning and that in your model right so
you would teach it to be a good part um
in my latest design which isn't finished
yet the robot does want to win
but at the moment it's it just won't it
just plays the game
um but if if somebody tells it that
cheating
is good it does believe that cheating is
good at the moment
so that's not very desirable so you have
to find some way to kind of
i think that's where the risk comes into
it and you have to have a governance
process out on the x
outside which kind of manages
what inputs are going into the ai
well you don't have the problem of the
hard coding and who who can devise all
these very complicated and complex rules
for you
upfront yeah right thanks